Trascrizione: Matteo Grigolato
Revisore: Cecilia Secco
Era l'inizio del 1996, nelle Filippine.
Anna, di cui abbiamo cambiato il nome
per proteggerne l'identità,
era al culmine della sua carriera.
Anna era la direttrice esecutiva
di un'istituzione importante.
Una sera, ad una festa aziendale,
era tardi;
e il suo capo, il presidente
dell'istituzione,
si offre di portarla a casa.
Però non l'accompagna a casa:
la porta in un motel.
Dove, alla fine, la violenta.
Nei prossimi minuti,
simulerò il vero controesame
che si è tenuto allora
nel tribunale delle Filippine.
In questa scena, l'avvocato difensore
dell'imputato, quindi del suo capo,
interroga Anna.
- Lasci che la riporti a quella notte:
era ad una festa aziendale.
Ad un certo punto, nella sua testimonianza
dice di avere capito che era mezzanotte.
- Sì.
- E ad un certo punto
il mio cliente, il suo capo,
si offre di accompagnarla a casa?
- Sì.
- Nella sua testimonianza dice che, cito:
"Ad un certo punto del viaggio,
mi sono resa conto
che stava guidando
in una direzione opposta a casa mia".
- Sì, mi ha portata in un motel.
- Lei ha cercato di scappare,
durante il tragitto?
- Sì, ma mentre cercavo di afferrare
il volante in macchina,
per deviare o fermare la macchina
e cercare di scappare,
ho sentito una pistola nella sua tasca.
- Non ha sentito una pistola!
Ha sentito quello che lei
pensava fosse una pistola.
Il mio cliente non possiede pistola,
né ha una licenza per possederne una.
La verità, Anna, è che lei
si è inventata tutto.
- No, non è vero.
- Successivamente, la macchina
si è fermata davanti al motel?
- Sì.
- La distanza tra il parcheggio
e la camera è di circa dieci metri:
è uno spazio pubblico.
È corretto dire che, se avesse urlato,
qualcuno l'avrebbe sentita?
- Come ho detto prima,
ho pensato che avesse una pistola.
Avevo paura.
Penso di aver provato ad urlare,
sinceramente non ci sono riuscita.
- Risponda alla domanda: se avesse urlato,
qualcuno l'avrebbe sentita?
- Sì, e penso di aver
provato ad urlare.
- Il motel ha avuto 20 ospiti,
quella notte, venti ospiti!
Ogni singolo ospite ha riferito
che non ha avvertito nulla
di strano quella notte.
- Ero scioccata, non ero
del tutto cosciente.
- Non era del tutto cosciente?
Ha appena detto che stava
afferrando il volante
mentre guidava per convincerlo
a fermare la macchina.
Ovviamente era in grado!
In quel momento, Anna,
lei avrebbe avuto l'occasione
di correre, scappare,
urlare, chiedere aiuto;
e invece non lo ha fatto.
- Ero completamente scioccata:
non pensavo razionalmente
o agivo logicamente.
- Anna, che posizione occupa
nel posto di lavoro?
- Sono la direttrice esecutiva.
- È la direttrice esecutiva
di una nota azienda, Anna,
quindi non è sicuramente una persona
che si lascia intimidire facilmente.
- No.
- Ecco perché la sua storia
sembra così difficile da credere!
- La mia posizione e personalità
non hanno nulla a che fare
con il modo in cui rispondo nella paura.
Ho fatto del mio meglio,
ma ero anche sotto choc.
- Continua a dire,
nella sua testimonianza,
che il mio cliente
l'ha bloccata sul letto,
e poi ha perso conoscenza.
E quando ha ripreso conoscenza,
lui la stava violentando?
- Sì.
Lei ha fatto qualcosa
per scappare o resistere?
- Sì, a volte resistevo,
ma a volte mi sentivo incapace
di muovermi, come paralizzata.
- Paralizzata?
La completa paralisi è qualcosa di nuovo,
nella sua testimonianza.
La mia conclusione
è che lei e il mio cliente, il suo capo,
avete avuto una relazione
sessuale consensuale.
- No, non è vero. Lui mi ha violentata.
- La verità è che ha sentito vergogna,
per aver avuto un rapporto
sessuale con il suo capo
e se n'è pentita.
- No, non è vero!
- Anna, come è tornata a casa la sera?
- Mi ha portato lui.
- È qui che la sua versione, Anna,
diventa ancora più non credibile:
lei ha testimoniato di aver passato
una notte orribile,
in cui è stata presumibilmente violentata,
e alla fine di tutto,
ha lasciato che il suo aggressore
la riportasse a casa.
- Ripeto: ero scioccata,
non sapevo cosa stessi facendo.
Sono andata dal dottore
il giorno successivo.
- La mia conclusione
è che lei ha chiaramente
inventato questa storia
per coprire i suoi rimpianti
e la sua vergogna.
Ora usciamo dall'aula
del Tribunale per un minuto:
quanti di voi hanno pensato -
fatemi vedere le mani -
che l'avvocato difensore dell'imputato
avesse qualche punto valido
nella sua argomentazione?
Posso vedere le mani?
Non siete in pochi.
Seconda domanda: quanti di voi pensano
che l'imputato sia stato assolto
dal crimine di stupro?
Grazie.
Questo caso è emblematico,
perché racchiude tutto ciò che c'è
di sbagliato e moralmente corrotto
nei sistemi giudiziari mondiali,
che non proteggono mai le vittime.
L'obiettivo di questo interrogatorio,
di questo controesame,
era di fare a pezzi completamente
la testimonianza di Anna,
parola per parola,
dettaglio per dettaglio,
facendo vedere che è lei in colpa,
e non il suo aggressore.
Prima di svelarvi cosa è successo
alla fine del processo,
vorrei riportarvi a due anni fa,
quando ci sono state rivelazioni
di abuso e violenza sessuale
ad opera del produttore cinematografico
statunitense Harvey Weinstein.
Da allora, una ragazza
inizia un movimento sui social network
che si chiama #metoo,
che in inglese vuol dire "anche io",
facendo un invito aperto
a quante più donne possibili
di denunciare, di raccontare
le loro storie,
così svelando la grave frequenza
di abuso di potere e abuso di autorità
da parte di uomini su donne
in migliaia di note ditte nel mondo,
ma anche in istituzioni politiche,
sociali, umanitarie e sportive.
E penso sia una ferita dolente
per tante noi, qua dentro,
ciò di cui sto parlando.
L'obiettivo del movimento
era di far vedere
la grandezza del problema,
e l'iniziativa è riuscita:
dal 2017 a oggi,
più di 20 milioni di donne
hanno denunciato una storia
di abuso o molestia sessuale,
soprattutto sul posto di lavoro.
20 milioni di verità,
20 milioni di ingiustizie -
e queste sono quelle che sappiamo:
immaginate tutte quelle
che noi non sappiamo,
tutte quelle che rimarranno
per sempre impunite.
Perché, secondo voi,
20 milioni di donne hanno deciso
di affidarsi ai social network
invece che ai processi giudiziari
e ai sistemi giudiziari?
Esattamente per quello
che ho fatto vedere in questa simulazione:
perché non sono credute.
Lo sapete che, globalmente,
un processo giudiziario su mille
finisce a favore della vittima?
Secondo gli ultimi dati ISTAT
dell'ultimo semestre,
in Italia sette milioni di donne
hanno subito, almeno una volta
nella vita, una forma di violenza.
Il femminicidio,
ovvero l'omicidio di una donna
da parte di un uomo,
è un fenomeno che non sembra arrestarsi.
Dal 2000 al 2018, quindi in otto anni,
più di 3000 donne sono state uccise.
Nel 72 percento dei casi
era ad opera di un ex, un parente
o dell'attuale compagno.
A SAHR, la nostra organizzazione,
difendiamo i diritti delle donne
completamente calpestate
in terre lontane come l'Afghanistan.
Ma quello su cui vorrei concentrarmi ora
è che la dinamica per cui
una donna, in Afghanistan,
è imprigionata per essere
stata violentata -
si, avete capito bene:
è lei che va in prigione in Afghanistan,
non il suo aggressore -
è la stessa per cui qui, in Italia,
tre donne alla settimana sono uccise,
in media, tramite femminicidio.
E quando sopravvivono
sono colpevolizzate, ridicolizzate,
la loro storia viene messa in dubbio:
forse hanno le guardie del corpo,
forse l'aggressore le vive vicino.
Dunque, la prossima volta
che una donna muore ammazzata
dopo aver denunciato tante volte,
non è colpa sua,
me dell'inefficacia dello Stato
e di leggi non adeguate.
Per la mia organizzazione, SAHR,
è fondamentale combattere questo sistema,
che si chiama "Sistema del patriarcato".
Un sistema di dominio maschile
in ogni ambito della vita quotidiana.
La storia della violenza sulle donne,
è strettamente legata all'idea, arcaica,
della donna come proprietà privata,
quindi come oggetto non autonomo,
e noi stiamo cercando di ristabilire
delle idee generali
su cosa vuol dire essere donna oggigiorno,
e far uscire le loro verità.
Ritornando al processo di Anna,
vi dirò cosa è successo.
Anna è stata otto anni in contenzioso,
otto anni di processo.
Ha fatto appello alla Corte
Suprema delle Filippine,
la Corte Suprema non le ha creduto
perché c'erano troppi dubbi e buchi
nella sua testimonianza.
Anna e la sua famiglia
hanno sofferto incommensurabilmente.
Hanno dovuto lasciare la loro città
perché la gente li derideva, dicendo:
"perché avete intentato causa
contro un uomo così rispettabile,
un uomo così influente?
Avreste perso comunque".
E lo Stato non l'ha protetta.
Anna fu costretta a dimettersi
dal suo ruolo di direttrice esecutiva.
E secondo voi, chi l'ha sostituita?
Un uomo pagato il doppio di lei,
così per evitare che una donna
sia nella sua posizione,
ed eventuali problemi con nuove accuse
di violenze contro il presidente.
Due medici le hanno diagnosticato
il disturbo post-trumatico da stress,
Anna cadde in un lungo
periodo di depressione,
e non riuscì più a trovare lavoro.
Allora vediamo:
qualcuno di voi ha alzato la mano
pensando che forse l'avvocato avesse
qualche argomentazione valida.
È esattamente così
che gli avvocati difensori degli imputati
discreditano le vittime
facendo sembrare che mentano,
che non si ricordino:
mettono in dubbio,
adirittura, le loro memorie.
E a questo segue
un crudele protocollo di domande
mirate a far sembrare
la vittima la colpevole.
Quindi, se foste voi gli avvocati di Anna,
e doveste convincere
una giuria, o un giudice,
che Anna è innocente,
come spieghereste il fatto
che non è scappata quando poteva,
che a volte resisteva,
a volte era in choc,
a volte era paralizzata.
Come spieghereste tutto ciò?
Ci sono spiegazioni legittime,
e il lavoro delle nostra organizzazione
è di fare rientrare le storie,
e le argomentazioni delle vittime,
nei Pubblici Ministeri e nei Tribunali:
questo è quello che facciamo
nel lavoro di difesa legale
della nostra organizzazione.
Il punto fondamentale qui, il problema,
è come la nostra società
percepisce lo stupro.
L'immaginario è che lo stupro
sia sempre commesso da uomini mostruosi,
in cui la vittima urla,
scalpita, si difende, fugge.
In cui ci sono lesioni fisiche evidenti,
quindi prove inconfutabili.
Ma non è così.
La maggior parte degli stupri
avviene da persone
che le vittime conoscono,
non sono perfetti sconosciuti:
anzi, sono ritenuti uomini
simpatici e rispettabili.
Quando una donna è vittima
in una situazione di pericolo,
lei non agisce o pensa razionalmente,
è un meccanismo automatico del corpo
che parte automaticamente
per sopravvivere
all'esperienza del trauma.
E quindi, una donna vittima cosa fa?
Negozia col suo aggressore,
lo supplica, cerca un altro modo - perché?
Per evitare la fatalità più grande,
quindi l'omicidio.
Per evitare che l'aggressore
arrivi ad ammazzarla,
a volte si sottomette alla violenza:
e quando ci si sottomette alla violenza,
c'è la paralisi e la dissociazione.
Per questo si è fatta portare a casa
dal suo aggressore.
Quindi tutto ciò
ha una spiegazione legittima
che va anche nella neurobiologia,
e questi sono alcuni dei casi
a cui noi lavoriamo.
Noi ci facciamo portavoce
e difensori dei diritti violati,
in modo che queste voci
possano essere ascoltate da un giudice,
in modo che un giudice capisca
le reazioni di una vittima.
È il 2019,
e non dovremmo trovarci in situazioni
in cui delle organizzazioni
cercano di aiutare delle donne
ad avere testimonianze più forti
davanti ai Pubblici Ministeri.
Ma questa è la situazione.
Nel mondo ci sono quattro miliardi
di ragazze e bambine
che sono fuori dallo stato di diritto.
Ci sono più di 190 paesi
al mondo, come sapete,
e più di 150 paesi al mondo
hanno almeno una legge
che discrimina donne e bambine.
Ciò che facciamo nella mia organizzazione,
io e le mie coraggiosissime colleghe,
alle quali oggi va tutto il mio cuore
e tutto il mio pensiero,
cerchiamo di capovolgere
questi giochi di potere,
cercando di smontare il meccanismo
per cui le disuguaglianze si perpetuano,
per cui l'abuso di autorità, e di potere,
continua in tantissime istituzioni
che noi conosciamo,
principalmente perché sennò
le donne non arriveranno mai
a realizzare il loro potenziale,
se non c'è almeno una difesa legale
nei casi in cui non vengono protette,
o minacciate o addirittura assassinate.
Questo è quello che noi abbiamo fatto
negli scorsi dieci anni.
La cosa per noi molto importante
è anche l'attitudine,
perché non si aiuta per aiutare
o per sentirsi bene,
ma perché abbiamo un privilegio:
siamo nate con il privilegio
di un passaporto, di una classe sociale,
di un colore della pelle,
Quindi, quando si nasce con un privilegio
si ha la responsabilità di metterlo
a disposizione degli altri.
Nella nostra organizzazione,
abbiamo deciso di farlo per le donne,
ma noi tutti possiamo metterlo
a disposizione di qualunque persona
che magari sta fuggendo da una guerra,
che ha bisogno di altre cose,
e questo è un po' anche il messaggio
con cui vi vorrei lasciare.
(Applausi)